Matt look this morning everybody was
optimistic they thought the deal was
going to get done tonight in Brussels we
thought that everything was going to
work out fine in the markets the markets
were off to the races but since then
European finance ministers have given us
the ice bucket treatment effectively
pouring a lot of cold water and ice all
over this optimism they're saying that
the deal doesn't have enough detail yet
they're saying that they've got it too
late and therefore can't do the
procedure work they need so yeah where
are we we're gonna have to wait and see
we've got the the finance ministers
meeting now and we get the leaders a
little bit later on can they pull the
rabbit out of a hat we don't know which
site to believe there's a lot of
confusion who is right and the optimist
right or the pessimists right we're
going to find out over the next few
hours guy you know we talk about
deadlines all the time and I'm sure
every viewers and those of us here in
the office get sick of hearing about it
but this feels like we've really reached
a moment here where something has to
happen I know that grief Greece got
another boost in its emergency liquidity
assistance over the weekend or early
this morning the guess we're going to
talk to help bring Greece in the euro
zone said he would take all of his money
out of a bank if he were in Greece are
things really coming to a head here I
think they probably are mad but as with
all these things when you think that
it's a crunch day with with grease that
turns out that there's another one next
Tuesday so I think we're going to see a
few more of these over the next few days
there's a whole bunch of meeting
schedule for the rest of the week we've
got another Eurogroup meeting that's the
finance ministers and then we've got
another leaders summit towards the back
end of this week I think today is just
the start of what is likely to be a kind
of a week long process the ECB's now
dishing out money on a daily basis to
make sure that the grease can see can
keep taking their money out of the Greek
banks has you just been talking about
and then we've got the the IMF deadline
coming up so there's a whole bunch of
things still to happen and I think today
yeah maybe just the start of what is
going to be a kind of few days of ups
and downs and waiting to seize and I
think we've still got a long way to go
whether or not there's a deal tonight
will we see the Greek banks opening
tomorrow morning
what will the ECB do we don't know the
answers to any of these questions we
just gotta wait and see and I think
after five years I guess you should be
pretty used to that right hit